the most powerful force that defines
religion is society it's very important
to understand that religion is an ever
malleable thing it there is no such
thing as Christianity it doesn't exist
there are Christianity's and the way
that one defines the gospel the way that
one understands Jesus as either the son
of god or the Messiah or as a you know a
great teacher to to to emulate the way
that one place is sort of the
Christology or even the cradle formula
of Catholicism has everything to do with
where one lives if you are a Catholic
living in suburban Denver with your two
and a half kids in your car in your
house your Jesus is probably a white
blond-haired blue-eyed peacenik who
turns the other cheek if you're a
Catholic living in the hills of
Guatemala your Jesus besides being
Mexican is a fighter a liberator one who
stands up to the oppressor and indeed
who takes up arms against oppression
it's the same Jesus it's the same
Catholicism but the understanding is
radically different depending on where
you live the same of course is true of
Islam if you're a Muslim living in
Detroit then your idea of Islam is a
religion of peace and submission and and
pluralism if you're a Muslim living on a
garbage heap on Gaza then your version
of Islam is as a religion of social
justice so everywhere that you go you
will see different expressions different
manifestations of what can be called the
same religion the same faith and I think
that we need to understand that because
in
way too often we look at the differences
between religious communities as being
defined as differences in religion and
frankly it's more often differences of
community than it is of religion
religion is an ever evolving process if
a religion stops evolving it dies and
there are thousands and thousands of
examples of dead religions in the world
that we can talk about that simply went
away because they were not able to adapt
to the constant changes of human
civilization in human societies the
reason we talk about the great religions
Islam Christianity Judaism Hinduism
Buddhism these five massive world
religions that have been around for
thousands of years and that have
billions of worldwide followers what
makes them great is because they are
constantly adapting they're constantly
evolving that's why they continue to
exist the moment you stop adapting the
moment you stop evolving to whatever
social political economic or cultural
landscape that the religion finds itself
in the mats the moment in which it goes
away